it's a very surreal experience I mean as
you could see I got a little emotional a
lot emotional so and it was like even
watching the series back myself I it was
a nostalgic kind of like wow that like
it brought up the feelings of what was
happening in that current time but like
to really even more of the emotional
side of like wow I have like really
evolved so much since then so it wasn't
like a sad cry it was more of like a I'm
proud of you I don't I can't married you
and I hope that you can appreciate that
and respect that decision of mine I had
a moment with my mom and so I spoke to
it you know while we were all together
as a group but that was a lot of stuff
all coming together at once and and so
my fears of you know I don't know
embarrassment my fears of you know like
I had stressed or disappointed someone
in comes like almost embarrassment like
I'd brought people into something that I
was clearly frustrated with because it
wasn't what the perception was right and
so we've been committed to you know
seeing the experience through but what's
not shown is that like she and I had
conversations multiple times also with
the cameras recording like we're
adamantly not gonna get married like
that was that's actually that was never
that was never something that we were
gonna do and so much so that we were
both calculated in the manner of you
know even when we had an engagement it's
an experiment we're just doing the best
we can to fall along with it so we had a
you know conversation in the day prior
to the engagements of we both know what
tomorrow is
we both have appreciated this experiment
if you understand that I'll give you
hear me you know are you okay with what
happens tomorrow like basically let me
preface like before I look like an
absolute crazy person and propose
through a wall which is just absolutely
crazy it is I just wanted to make sure
that we were both seeing the eye-to-eye
right like we hadn't get lost in the
cosmos that was the show and so we
didn't and that that allowed us to get
to the next step
you know we appreciate it obviously the
experiment from start to finish being in
cancun was super fun and we'll always
have those memories right and that's
that's what life's all about
very seldom honestly you know I actually
reached out probably about four months
ago and it was more of a 1 even about if
the show comes out right because because
that was a hypothetical that existed
from the moment that we stopped filming
a lot of people would understand that
either but like from the moment we
stopped filming all of our friends all
our family now is like let give us you
know the two months three months span
where all you wanted to do was just
disconnect and get back to reality
everything was changed everything was
different and so it took months for us
just to get settled and so that was a
conversation that we had that no one
know it was like I respect your space
you respect my space I need to get back
to you my core values my friends my
family and you know I think it would be
a good idea if you do the same and so we
really respected that you know I
personally didn't date for the you know
7 & 8 months afterwards but you know a
lot of life changes happen between them
and so it's just that's that's kind of I
did go through more of a serious
relationship or dating I guess um but
that was probably a good six or seven
months after the fact I'd gone on a
couple of dates but I like I was very
much set in like I remember going on a
date and I was like listen I've been
there done that I'm not fixing anyone
anymore so like if you're not ready do
this ain't gonna work
[Music]